no my pious and merciful brother may God
stand by you as well as by ourselves
with a spirit coming from him that we
the group of the brethren of purity and
pure and Noble friends have been asleep
in the cave of our Father Adam for a
long time and during the vicissitudes of
time and misfortunes of existence this
was written by a group of scholars in
the 10th century who called themselves
the Quan Asafa which means the brethren
of purity now they are famous for a
group of epistles that they wrote
probably ambassador Iraq in a
fascinating period in the Middle East
now what is especially interesting about
this group aside from their writings
themselves is that we still actually
don't know who they were
[Music]
the ninth 10th and 11th centuries were a
vibrant time for the so called Muslim
world that is lands that were ruled by
Muslim leaders the Abbasid Caliphate is
often viewed as a kind of Golden Age of
science philosophy and learning and
there is some truth to this claim
because the Abbasid caliphs were often
patrons of science and an rational
inquiry and an arts as well Calif like
Al Mamun established and ran the Bayt
al-hikma the House of Wisdom in Baghdad
in which texts were translated from
Greek and and people from different
religious and cultural backgrounds came
together to discuss theological
religious philosophical ideas by the
10th century there has started to
develop a kind of Orthodoxy in Islamic
orthodoxy after centuries of debates
regarding theological and legal and
philosophical questions those who were
more sort of opposed to rational inquiry
and and thinking was starting to gain
more ground and they were also the ones
who often determined what this conceived
orthodoxy was to become but in spite of
this philosophy and philosophers were
still going strong so to speak and some
of the most famous thinkers do appear
around this time people like Al Farabi
Ivan Cena and Haytham and Baroni and
many many more it should be remembered
that at this point as in earlier periods
islam and the lands ruled by its leaders
was a diverse and multifaceted culture
with many competing ideas and claims to
leadership not only were there competing
a sort of political religious factions
such as the alador so-called shia and ab
acid or what would be later called sunni
but also in terms of how revelation the
law and its application should be viewed
it is in this historical context that
the group calling themselves the iran
Asafa or brethren of purity appears they
are what could be called a secret
society or a brotherhood of a few
mysterious individuals most like
from Becerra who would gather for secret
meetings discussing philosophical and
theological questions although there
have been guesses and theories regarding
the identity of these scholars
throughout history they have remained
anonymous as they sort of made a great
point of never revealing who they
actually were most of what we know about
the Brethren come from what is called
their Asylum annasophia or the epistles
of the brethren of purity which is a
collection of over 50 epistles or
treaties written by them each of which
deals with specific philosophical
subjects this includes things like
mathematics cosmology astronomy music
the law the soul and many more as one
would expect the hewan are heavily
influenced by Greek philosophy and upon
closer inspection we becomes pretty
clear that they are especially fond of
the school of neoplatonism now if you
want more information about that school
in particular there are some previous
videos I have made where I discussed
this point this very strong affiliation
with Neoplatonism do suggest something
about their identity indeed a lot of
scholars do sort of agree that the
Brethren will most probably belong at
least to the Shia branch of Islam based
on some other references to the Imams
the the spiritual leaders of Shia Islam
in particular the epistles suggests to a
lot of scholars that the the Brethren
were smileys which is the second-largest
branch of Shia Islam today which makes
sense based on its contents because
these smileys were especially fond of
neoplatonism even if most other Muslim
theologians and philosophers were
heavily influenced by it at this time
now these smileys were perhaps their
greatest fans the ones who adapted most
of those ideas but what did they say you
may ask what was the message of these
epistles and the Brethren this is of
course a very difficult question to
answer but we can try to grasp in a
general sense the outlook of the sort of
the general outlook of these very
secretive individuals a good source for
this is actually in a quote by a sunni
scholar hostile to the group called
mahayana tahiti who seems to have an
idea of who these people are and states
that crow
one cannot assign him some guy names I'd
even refer to any such thing as a group
because of his excited nature and
acceptable Ian's sorry in every domain
and one cannot tell what comes from the
breath of his insight and what comes
from his powerful tongue he lived in
Basra for a long time and met there a
group of people devoted to all kinds of
Sciences and arts the group was
characterized by harmonious relations
and pure friendship and met on the base
of holiness purity and sincere advice
between them they established a doctrine
by which they claimed they would be able
to get closer to winning God's approval
and travelling to his paradise for they
used to say the revelation has been
soiled by ignorance and mixed with error
there is no way to wash and purify it
except through philosophy which United
the wisdoms of the Creed with the
benefit of rational endeavor perfection
would be reached they held when Greek
philosophy and Arab revelation were
joined they composed 50 epistles in all
parts of philosophy both theoretical and
practical and attached a table of
contents to them calling them the
epistles of the brethren of purity and
loyal friends and quote thus we can
deduce from this that the one considered
the Quran the Islamic revelation and
rational philosophy not to be not
positioned to each other but to actually
complement each other and to be
important complements for each other now
this wasn't entirely uncommon at this
time as many other Muslim philosophers
would hold the same idea but the hewan
adds to this that the religion of Islam
has been ruined even defiled by the
literalist minded scholars who have led
the people astray and an sort of get
done away with rationality which they
considered to be a very important part
of religion the whole mission of the
Brethren and their writings is an
idealist one where they seek to mend
this disease of ignorance that is
plaguing the Muslim world according to
them by reintroducing people to the
complementary relationship of religion
and philosophy and science and by doing
so purifying Islam to its pristine state
this was done through their secret
meetings in which they too
cus these questions and most likely
performed certain spiritual practices
together perhaps similar to the
developing Sufis of the time and by
writing the epistles for a larger
audience of readers to help them on the
spiritual and rational path the Brethren
saw themselves as loyal friends who
helped each other reach spiritual purity
and as mentioned in the quote to reach
paradise as you might expect this didn't
go over too well with some of the other
Islamic scholars of the emerging
orthodoxy
they were often branded as heretics and
as being outside of the fold of Islam
but others especially the smileys view
the epistles of the Brethren as highly
important some have even called it the
Quran of the Imams based on an idea that
its author may have been one of the
Imams himself this skepticism towards
the hewan isn't all too surprising given
the fact that a lot of the ideas
expressed in the epistles come up as
very unusual and strange as
interpretations of the Islamic
revelation like other philosophers they
adhere to the neo platonic metaphysics
of emanation starting with the one
identified with God who is completely
unknowable and beyond attributes
followed by the intellect the world soul
and continuing down to our material
world the human being is a microcosm and
in sun and Sahir literally the small man
that perfectly reflects the macrocosm
that is the cosmos at large and in sanh
and Kabir the big man an idea that was
heavily used by later thinkers for
example a banana B has a very similar
idea the goal of this human being is to
distance himself or not get attached to
mundane material worldly things and
instead focus on the spiritual and
intellectual world of knowledge in order
to have a blissful afterlife related to
this they also read and interpreted the
Quran and very allegorical and
metaphorical ways so this sort of
blissful or hellish afterlife is a
spiritual one so hell or paradise are
not actual locations places they are
states of the soul on its journey back
towards primeval unity in this sort of
neo platonic metaphysical emanation
scheme and so what they did
use what's known as tow wheel or
esoteric interpretation to deduce these
secrets and hidden meanings behind the
outer quranic verses and chapters
something that is especially common in
Shia Islam and in particular also in the
smile ISM these - were sometimes known
as the baton Nia by their contemporaries
the baton is this hidden aspect of the
Quran and so they were they were sort of
named because of their sort of infamous
love for a toe for toe wheel and for
buttons of the hidden esoteric meanings
rather than the outer Zhou had literal
meanings and this this process of toe
wheel esoteric interpretation were often
guided by the Imams themselves so the
Imams had the authority to know what was
a moment say our authoritative a
legitimate interpretation in that sense
but in this allegorical interpretation
is where they present some of the most
surprising ideas for example the concept
of balisok referred to in the Quran as a
sort of middle stage between death and
the final day of judgment is interpreted
by the want to mean a kind of cycle of
rebirths that sort of unpurified souls
must endure until they reach perfection
were the coming sort of the large day of
judgment at the end of time this concept
of rebirth is somewhat different from
that in Indian traditions for example
since Moomin Souls never come animals
for example but it does show you that
you can rarely say anything generalizing
about any religion the idea that Islam
doesn't teach reincarnation would be
agreed upon by most people but here we
see that there have been Muslims who
have even considered this concept they
also view time is cyclical and used a
lot of astrology to support this theory
the number seven is constantly recurring
for example each cycle is made up of
seven thousand years after which there
will be a mini day of judgments sort of
different from the larger proper day of
judgment at the end of time and in the
cycle of seven thousand years each
thousand years is associated with a
prophetic cycle that is a time when the
law of a particular prophet reigns so
the first thousand years was the cycle
of Adam followed by Abraham
Jesus and lastly Mohammed associated
with the current sixth cycle the seventh
cycle will begin at the coming of al
mahdi who will redeem the world before
the seven thousand year cycle have come
to its conclusion they connect this
theory to the story in the Koran and the
Bible that God created the world in six
days before resting or sitting on his
throne on the seventh this to them is a
metaphor for these prophetic cycles than
that the world goes through and this is
also thus a perfect example of two wheel
of esoteric interpretation as such as
crazy as this may sound it's a rather
common idea within Shiism and especially
smile ism and it would actually be the
basis upon which a lot of the sort of
groundwork of the Baha'i faith is based
as well there's plenty of other really
fascinating aspects of the epistles and
the ideas that are brought up in them
they are sort of a collection or
synthesis of a whole myriad of different
sources and this in fact is one of the
most interesting and noteworthy aspects
of the the brethren the one I think
which is their open-mindedness to-to-to
knowledge from all kinds of directions
as I mentioned they are highly
influenced of course by Greek philosophy
not just Neoplatonism but the Greeks in
general but they also take ideas from
Persian philosophy like Zoroastrianism
for example and certain ideas from India
Indian thinking especially when it comes
to astronomy a lot of Indian influences
in terms of astronomy and of course the
sacred scriptures these are also very
important sources of knowledge for them
and also not worthy is that this is not
extort of exclusively the Quran it is
also a much broader sort of range of
scriptures indeed the Quran is of course
very important to the one as it is
quoted constantly to support their ideas
but so is the Torah the Psalms and the
Gospels to the brethren knowledge was
knowledge and was always valuable quotes
now you must know that the science is
based on human wisdom and those based on
prophetic revelation are fields of study
which agree about the aim they pursue
the fundamental points while
disagreeing about the ramifications and
quote this fundamental point being the
purification of the soul which can be
reached by revelation or by philosophy
or more specifically in this case by a
combination of both of these when it
comes to these sacred scriptures there
is little discrimination here of course
the Quran is the most important and
exalted of the scriptures but the others
like the Torah and the Gospels are also
considered equally authoritative the
author whose name I will not butcher by
saying God Freud the callate writes
quote that the Brethren clearly do think
that the Quran ranked above
philosophical writings they just did not
think that it did so alone all revealed
books here occupy the same level in the
hierarchy of knowledge all are superior
to literature produced by ordinary
humans and all seem to be endowed with
the same Authority and quote but it
should also be remembered that the
knowledge that were conveyed and
discussed by the hewan was not meant for
everyone but specifically for sort of
brothers and for educated people indeed
The Hondas divided society into certain
categories starting with the sort of
common uneducated masses who only
followed the outer aspects of the law
secondly there are those who are capable
of interpreting revelations and the law
like theologians and jurists and lastly
the group that they Brethren themselves
belong to the so-called chosen few who
had mastery both of religious sciences
and rational ones which they could
combine to study the the hidden secrets
were the hidden Sciences of religion as
such the Awan were highly skeptical and
hostile towards the legalistically and
literalist oriented muslims of their day
who were they viewed as hypocrites and
ignorant the law was necessary of course
on a societal level and they affirmed
its importance but the law itself wasn't
able to carry the person all the way to
the higher truths he was only there as a
medicine for six souls as they say and
was thus the lowest form of religion
mostly meant for those uneducated masses
in the first category true religion was
the hidden secrets hidden Sciences that
they studied in spite of their apparent
elitism and
not to mention the very sort of
unorthodox ideas and unusual ideas they
present in the pistols the one the
brethren of purity have been a hugely
influential group of people throughout
Muslim history
indeed in medieval times most
well-educated people had read the
epistles
this includes people like eben Cena lb
Roni Sora Hardy and even someone like
eben tamiya read them even if they may
seem wacky and strange at times the the
one must be admired for their huge
undertaking in the epistles and their
willingness to combine knowledge of
religion and philosophy and also of
course their mastery of both of these
fields indeed their open-mindedness to
many different sources of knowledge
allowed them to come up with some very
original ideas and this I'm sort of
spirit of syncretism should I think be
admired in itself they themselves wrote
quotes
know this my brother we are not opposed
to any science we do not cling
fanatically to any doctrine and we do
not keep ourselves away from any of the
books that the sages and the
Philosopher's have written or composed
on the various sciences as for the
support assistance and foundation of our
cause they are the books of the prophets
revelation which they have set forth as
well as the information inspiration and
revelation passed to them by the Angels
I'll see you next time
[Music]